joining us now is the environment
minister george eustis hello to you mr
eustis a bit of a surprise that we saw
our own pm um in kiev cementing um i
suppose the conviction that the brits
are doing what they can to support
ukraine in this their hour of need
well absolutely in fact i think the
whole world is coming together to show
you know solidarity and support of
ukraine about what's happened that's why
the prime minister announced yesterday
that we would be making available more
you know defensive military equipment
to the ukrainians additional missiles
and so on we've been giving them support
from from the beginning but also it's so
important that we remain absolutely
resolute when it comes to sanctions
against russia we must ensure
that putin cannot prevail on this uh the
ukrainians have been incredibly uh brave
i think president zielenski has led his
people well and we've all been humbled
really by the the acts of bravery we've
seen but also deeply shocked about some
of those terrible scenes that we're
seeing coming out now from the cities
from which russia has withdrawn yeah an
a-star then for the support for ukraine
on the ground but must try harder when
it comes
to refugees even priti patel the uh home
secretary apologizing for the fact that
we are not moving quickly enough to help
refugees who want to come to the uk
it's different for countries that are
bordering the ukraine because people are
fleeing a war like this obviously will
cross the nearest land border and that's
why countries like you know poland and
hungary obviously are getting
more of those refugees coming in but we
have now issued visas under the two
schemes we've got in particular the
sponsorship scheme to around 40 000
ukrainians and around 12 000 of those
are already here we've made some changes
already making clear for instance that
those with a ukrainian passport don't
need to attend an appointment in person
and um i know that pretty patel is
looking very closely at this to look at
whatever else can be done and to remove
any barriers as and when those arise
yeah well um dublin doesn't border
um ukraine either but they're doing a
lot better than we are
well look there are as i said some
differences
between uh countries but uh priti
patel's already made some changes
removing that need uh for an appointment
in person for those with a passport and
she's also made clear that if there's
other things that we can do to speed up
the process we will and there's been a
huge outpouring i think of generosity
around the country different local
authorities seeking to be involved that
we financially supported around 27 local
authorities to stand up hubs and
reception centers to help refugees that
are coming here and i think many people
want to do their bit to help
okay do you understand why people are
angry about the revelations about rishi
sunuk and his wife
well look rishi sunak and his wife are
spoken for themselves on this i'm not
his accountant i'm not responsible
obviously for his uh for his tax affairs
all those indeed of his wife she gave a
statement over the weekend she's now
made clear that although
she hasn't done anything wrong um you
know she uh she's a
citizen of india and um i grew up and
was born in india and has some income
from that nevertheless she's changing
her tax arrangement so that she would
pay the tax on that income here in the
uk and rishi himself has been some
speculation around that he's uh written
to the prime minister and asked the
advisor on ministerial standards to look
at this case uh he's very clear he's you
know declared um everything that should
have been declared at the right time and
there is a process here that you have as
a minister you declare all your
interests to the permanent secretary in
your department and the cabinet office
then you know decide which bits should
be made public which bits they should be
aware of there's a duty of candor in
both directions and rishi's very clear
that he's uh that he's he's been very
candid about his uh his own arrangements
at every stage
and in answer to my question
uh will your question um uh was with are
people angry about this and i've just
said out um the position and and how
they've responded to it yeah do you
understand why the british people are
angry that the man who has increased tax
for them his wife was not paying
tax on overseas income to the um extent
of millions of pounds do you understand
why there is anger amongst the british
public on that
well look i think people should judge
the chancellor he is saying you just say
yes i mean it's obvious it's obvious i
mean are you so out of touch as a
government that you don't understand
that people are struggling to feed their
kids whereas the man who's enforcing
these laws on them these taxes on them
uh his is rolling in it
well the man who uh is chancellor at the
moment has paid all of his taxes and
paid taxes on his uh income and declared
all of that in the uk he's been uh clear
about that and that's you know we of
course there is a pressure on cost of
living at the moment we all recognize
that that we all recognize that there
are some difficult decisions coming down
that the tracks when it comes to tax to
help get the nhs back on track but we're
also
doing all that we can to help people
through these difficult times okay uh
what about his green card i know he's
given it up now but he was
chancellor when he had a green card for
residency in another country while he
was responsible for uk tax
well look he worked in the united states
and said for many years um he was based
out there lived out there worked out
there and yes there was a
if you like a hangover from that period
when he was working in the u.s where he
retained that green card but obviously
uh he got rid of that a couple of years
ago i think um
i'm sure he was still an mp
in october
well
he's got rid of the green card now but
what i'm saying
he was responsible for uk tax uh while
he was resident in another country
that's according to don't take it from
me according to some of your
backbenchers saying that it doesn't pass
the political cricket test that you're
committed to the uk
well
all i'm saying is he worked in the
united states for a while during that
period he had a green card he kept that
green card for a period after that but
as i understand it hasn't affected the
tax that he's paid here in the uk that's
not my point my point is that he was a
resident in another country and he was
responsible for what you and i and my
viewers this morning pay in tax how does
that pass the test of fairness
well he had a green card
a u.s green card and i'm not an expert
on that i've never had one myself nor
would i ever seek to have one to be
honest uh but look uh he's now referred
himself to
the advisor uh on uh standards and of
ministerial interests and lord guide
we'll look at all of this and we'll
you know make an assessment about
whether he declared all the right things
at the right time
um sergey javid now revealing that he
previously had non-dom status can you
anticipate anybody else in the cabinet
coming forward to say the same thing
well um i don't all i can tell you as i
said i'm not uh the accountant for my uh
ministerial colleagues in cabinet i
don't know anybody who may or may not
have had non-dom status i can tell you
uh that i never have and we would never
seek to have one that's something we
have in common um should spices ever be
fair game
well look i think um
in reality i think when it comes to
politics we all know that there's a
heightened level of scrutiny for those
that get involved in politics and that
can affect family
should it i think it probably shouldn't
i think
politicians who put themselves up into
public life um expect that higher level
of scrutiny
often with that will come some extra
scrutiny on their family and that's
understood but i think um generally no i
think it should be the focus on those
elected politicians and what they do
principally in the job and um and i i
think it's wrong that family should be
drawn into it in that way
do you think that we
as the british public should have any
view on the fact that mrs murty although
she's now saying that she
will pay taxes on her foreign income
which could amount to many millions of
pounds she won't have to pay
inheritance tax because she's still
a non-dom that means she's going to save
potentially hundreds of millions of
pounds is that morally right
well as i said she is not the chancellor
and she's not in politics she's the wife
if i may interrupt you there minister no
but she she was for a long time living
in taxpayer-funded accommodation
well and she has made clear and you know
she's spoken for herself on these
matters she's not part of the government
it's not for me really to speak for her
but she has spoken for herself on this
that she's going to change her tax
arrangements so that she does pay
income tax on the income that she earns
from overseas there's nothing wrong with
what she's been doing but she said
nevertheless that she will
make that payment going forward and i
think it's for her really to to speak
for her own affairs on these matters
it's not for me as i said i'm not her
tax advisor and she's not part of the
government it's not really for me to
speak for her or her entire individual
personal tax effects no but my point is
that she was living with the family in
taxpayer-funded accommodation and she
was saving many many millions of pounds
by using her non-dom status that has
been brought to the public's attention
and the
would-be prime minister has now decided
that that will not happen going forward
but it's now become uncovered that um
she won't have to pay um
a tax on inheritance or she won't have
to pay inheritance tax and i'm asking
you whether you feel uh you must have a
view do you feel that that is morally
right
well the chancellor who's part of the
government has now you know referred
himself
to lord gates and asked him to
investigate all of his own arrangements
at all of his own tax affairs and what
he declared and what was made public on
his ministerial declaration at the time
that investigation will take place you
know the tax affairs of his wife are a
different matter and she has given an
account of that over the weekend made
clear that she intends to pay tax on
some of that foreign income going
forward and i think really you know it's
for her to talk about her own tax
affairs as i said i'm not qualified to
i'm not her accountant i'm not even an
accountant at all
but
you are representing the government this
morning and you know that's right she's
not part of the government
no but she lived in taxpayer-funded
accommodation we've made that clear
she's married to a man who wants to be
prime minister who is charging uh people
millions of pounds in taxes that they
can ill afford at the moment half a
million kids are in uh real poverty have
been plunged into real poverty as a
result of what's happened over the last
few weeks and months does it not offend
you in any way
well look i'm somebody as a cabinet
colleague of uh rishi sunak the
chancellor i judge minister of college
based on their performance in the role
and i think rishi tsunak has performed
very well as chancellor of the ex jacob
doing some extraordinarily difficult
times and he himself has now referred
himself to
lord gait the minister the prime
minister's advisor on ministerial
sanders to look at these matters
and i i'm really not going to get drawn
into commenting uh you know any further
than i have on his wife's tax affairs he
said i'm not qualified to she's given an
account of those herself every mp's
family at some level you know leaving
what you might call taxpayer-funded
accommodation because most mps obviously
you know maintain um a presence in both
london and in their constituencies okay
something i know that you do want to
talk about is the announcement that your
department is making today tell me more
fly tipping has been a a really
difficult problem in recent years
and what we are announcing today is a
couple of things first of all removing
the charge that some local authorities
around a third of them still charge
people for disposing of
items like plasterboard if they've been
doing diy we're going to remove
their ability to charge for that to you
know remove one of those incentives
perhaps for people to fly to these items
are often
associated with fly tipping but also
link to that on the enforcement side
we're supporting a number of local
authorities with some pilot schemes
using cctv in a creative way to try to
catch the criminals that are responsible
for fly tipping in most local
authorities it's a relatively small
number of people we want to help them
identify who they are so that we can
bring them to justice and stop this
problem okay minister i must let you go
i know but it's always great to talk to
you hopefully see you soon thank you
very much thank you very much